what you got
do you see this this is what we have
been looking for this
is a fresh scene oh wow man look at that
it's a it's quite a fresh track of a
snow leopard how can you tell
oh you see these toes and the paw
you see the contours here they haven't
melted yet yeah yeah it's february 2020
and i'm hiking along a snowy ridgeline
overlooking a deep gorge
with national geographic explorer
prasanji yadav
i found another little cave up here
we're in the remote spiti valley of
northern india
it's sunny but below freezing and we're
trudging through
calf deep snow surrounded by pristine
white himalayan peaks usually on an
assignment
my only equipment is a pen and a
notebook but now i'm gathering sound for
the podcast
and i'm trying to keep my microphone
cord stuffed in my jacket to prevent it
from freezing and breaking
i'm gonna see if i can get up a little
closer to these blue sheep
i'm not a snow leopard so maybe that
won't mind meanwhile
prosanjit is on a mission and he's laser
focused on the ground you have a bright
sun
up here and still it hasn't melted so
my my speculation is this is either last
night or this morning
prasanji is used to navigating difficult
environments as a wildlife photographer
he's worked in monsoons jungles deserts
and uninhabited islands but this terrain
is by far the most extreme
first spitty is almost three miles above
sea level
unless you're born here the thin air
takes some serious getting used to
in the winter there's also heavy
snowfall howling winds and there's
always the threat of frostbite
did you find anything down there but if
you're really serious about catching a
glimpse of a snow leopard
you have to get up to their favorite
haunts and that means climbing icy
cliffs
we have climbed up like 300 meters now
and this is where the snow leopards move
quite often
we actually don't know that much about
snow leopards they're so difficult to
track
scientists can only guess at how many
there are maybe as few as 3 500 or as
many as 7
000 part of the reason we know so little
is due to the cats range which spans
roughly 800
000 square miles across 12 countries and
these are highly remote areas filled
with rugged terrain like the spiti
valley
so i have a i have a thought that
probably this snow leopard went up
and probably it must be looking for its
prey oh wow
so if we keep going up is there what's
the chance that we see
a snow leopard feeding on a on a kill
can you promise me that even though it's
winter
we're surrounded by areas that offer
just enough grasses poking through the
snow
for the ibex and blue sheep to graze on
the snow leopards here mainly hunt ibex
and blue sheep
so that makes this prime snow leopard
territory the prostitute still isn't
making any promises
this is a bright day and this time of
the day i have a feeling that snow
leopards would be sitting somewhere in
the
in the deep crevices in this ridge and
must be just resting the
the heat this kind of heat you mean we
climbed all the way up here for nothing
just some tracks it's not just
any track it's no leverage like think
about it
we are walking on the same path where
less than 24 hours ago a snow leopard
walk
i'm peter guinn editor at large at
national geographic magazine
and this is overheard at national
geographic a show where we eavesdrop on
the wild conversations we have here at
natgeo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week we travel to some of the
world's most rugged mountains
in search of one of the planet's most
elusive creatures
and learn how after centuries of
conflict with snow leopards
locals are now taking innovative steps
to conserve them and bring tourists to
see them
[Music]
more after the break
i was in college when i first read peter
matheson's classic book the snow leopard
and ever since i've been obsessed with
seeing one of these enigmatic cats in
the wild
by firelight we talk about the snow
leopard
not only is it rare but it is wary and
elusive to a magical degree
and so well camouflaged in the places it
chooses to lie
that one can stare straight at it from
yards away
and fail to see it matheson recounts his
journey in 1973 with legendary wildlife
biologist george schaller
to explore remote himalayan valleys
at the time snow leopards were like
mountain ghosts
in fact schaller was believed to be one
of only two westerners
known to even have seen a snow leopard
in the wild
and for the better part of 25 years a
single photo he had managed to snap
was the only image of a wild snow
leopard known to exist
and then there was the small matter of
the snow leopard
whose terrible beauty is the very stuff
of human longing
its uncompromising yellow eyes wired
into the depths of its unfathomable
spirit
gaze out from the cover of innumerable
additions
as the men trekked deeper into the
mountains they found signs of snow
leopards
all around them including several fresh
prints in the snow just like the one
prosenjeet showed me
have you seen the snow leopard no
isn't that wonderful on that trip
matheson never actually got to see a
snow leopard
but he felt certain they were watching
them the cat's presence haunted the
landscape
and it's haunted my imagination ever
since
can you describe this road that we're
driving up here this giant
scary road okay fast forward a bunch of
years
my buddy prostitute starts working on a
new project and
basically disappears months go by i send
emails
whatsapps nada and then suddenly
my phone lights up and it's filled with
pictures of a small mountain village in
northern india
called kibber prasanjit says you want to
see a snow leopard you got to come here
but there's a catch how do you feel
about heights is this movie called as
tokyo drift
and there's a song no don't don't talk
about tokyo drift when we're dropped on
these roads
on one side there's this cliff from
where there are shooting stones
there are these stones which completely
come loose
when the when the snow melts and they
literally fall down
onto the road and these stones could be
small or it could be
it could be really big boulders which
can literally crush your car
looks like some weather may be moving in
yeah
the good news he said was there was a
new road that went all the way to kibber
the bad news is it's a single track
hacked out of the side of a near
vertical cliff
it's barely wide enough for his jeep and
it's covered with snow and ice
and occasionally i feel the jeep start
to slide a little and to your left
there's this
big gorge which ends up into this river
and if your vehicle tumbles down there
then then you're gone
seriously i'm good
okay but here's the thing you have to
travel this road
in winter because that's when the snow
leopards follow their favorite prey
the blue sheep and the eye bags down
from the higher elevations
so that means braving the harsh winter
cold of the himalaya
and then hiking up into rocky cliffs
covered in ice and snow
you see them only when they are walking
as a black dot
in a in a white snow
their fur is a perfect blend of the
colors of the landscape
white tawny brown and smoky gray with
swirls of charcoal
that combination perfectly camouflages
the cats
and lets them disappear into any area
not completely covered by snow
but you remove the snow out of the
equation
and the snow leopard is just another
rock
in this vast rocky uh landscape
and that makes them so much more
difficult to spot
it's thrilling to catch sight of a wild
snow leopard just walking in the snow
but these creatures are like superheroes
in the animal kingdom
as climbers they make alex hunt look
like an amateur
they can leap up to 50 feet balance on
the thinnest ledges
and sprint in bursts as fast as a
racehorse
all this makes them one of the deadliest
hunters on the roof of the world
and if you're super lucky you might just
get to see a snow leopard hunt
about a year before i came here i saw a
jaw dropping video taken in 2018
of a snow leopard sprint after a blue
sheep and then go hurtling off a cliff
and then you see the snow leopard
literally
falling off from a cliff maybe 250
300 feet down and then you see it
falling and then rolling another couple
of hundred meters down
i am sure that no human being
can survive any such fall
and then it sat up and started eating
the sheep like
nothing happened i think that's that's
one of the
craziest naturalistic videos that exist
on the internet today
here's the catch a snow leopard requires
a massive territory
a male in kibber might need 40 square
miles or more
an area roughly twice the size of
manhattan to find enough prey to sustain
itself
but prosing is used to solving
complicated problems
he was working on a phd in molecular
ecology before deciding to become a
wildlife photographer
still this is almost a mission
impossible situation
the terrain is so rugged and the
temperatures are so extreme that finding
a snow leopard
is like finding a needle in a haystack
while trying not to lose a toad of
frostbite
prostate comes from the plains of india
where it's sea level and super hot
so the first challenge he faced when he
got here was just getting used to the
altitude
and the brutal cold my father has a farm
which is literally in the middle of a
jungle
and that's where i grew up and when i
say literally in the middle of jungle i
mean it like we have
tigers coming in our lawn even now so he
knows big cats
as a kid he came to recognize their
pungent smell
and could pick out their shadows moving
in the forest his family didn't bother
to name their dogs because
every six months or so they'd lose them
to the leopards that lurked around the
family's farm
which wasn't that far from the area that
inspired rudyard kipling's
the jungle book many friends still call
me moogly and
and it just me out but it is what it is
yeah
when he came to kippur prasanji knew he
had to learn to think like a snow
leopard
to get close-up photos and videos so we
set up camera traps in areas where
they're most likely to come through
do you want to smell it come closer put
your nose in there
we're in a cave high up on a cliff he
shows me a rock where his snow leopard
has urinated
and rubbed its face leaving bits of hair
as a mark of its territory
oh my gosh wow that's very pungent
yeah and and that kind of does smell
like my cat
when i was a kid it smells like this
there's a feline
sort of thing going on there yeah this
is also a cat just that it's
it's like much bigger
this cave is connected to a series of
ledges he calls the snow leopard
highway because the cats pass through
here frequently as they follow the ibex
and blue sheep
but getting an image is still tricky and
i get like
one decent picture every two months
there's a real art to getting a snow
leopard
to basically take a selfie i might have
hundreds of photos where
there are snow leopards inside the
camera trap and if it comes in
most of the times it it it loves to show
its bottom to the camera
you know there is one old male snow
leopard that's been the star of these
camera trap shoots
his territory appears to surround kibber
and i could identify
him because he had his
left ear chipped it was cut
and and and i started calling him uh cut
here or ear cut uh in in in our language
we used to call him khan kata
perhaps i think he loved taking taking
his selfies
prasanji has become obsessed with this
old male
he's pretty sure he's the father of two
cubs born to a female in 2019
and it was probably kankadar that
tumbled off the cliff in the viral video
i saw
which was actually shot just outside of
kibber and it's easy to get carried away
by these creatures
their spectacular physical prowess their
beauty
and their mystery but the people who
live in these mountains
they see snow efforts differently more
after this
the village of kibbur is nestled in
mountains at nearly 14 000 feet above
sea level
it was part of an ancient tibetan
kingdom and features a buddhist temple
where
for centuries monks have chanted in the
middle of each day
it's home to around 400 people and
pretty much forever they've tinted yaks
goats sheep and other livestock
every now and then a snow leopard would
kill one
and that was a major blow because those
animals are key to the family's survival
so when snowbirds killed livestock
people responded by hunting
crossing i paid a visit to tanzan finley
a 43 year old resident of the village
finley remembers when he was a kid a
snowbird once attacked
20 sheep at a neighbor's house prossenji
translated his story for me
and he locked him inside and the entire
village got agitated and came
with with spears and and and
knives and everything yeah and they
killed it
so for a long time residents of kibber
regarded the snow leopard as a threat to
their livelihoods
but that was until a young scientist
arrived in 1996.
my name is charu mishra and i'm
the executive director of the
international snow leopard trust
i've been basically a scientist uh
researcher and a conservationist
all my life years before charo got
involved with the snow upper trust
in doing conservation for the species he
was a 25 year old graduate student
interested in studying wildlife biology
in the himalaya
as charles studied the area's wildlife
he couldn't help but notice the stigma
around snow leopards so these predators
were such an
important part of people's lives i mean
you almost never saw them they almost
never saw them
and yet there was this constant presence
of these predators
but charlo had an idea what about
creating
insurance for livestock a resident could
pay a premium each year
and if a snow leopard killed one of
their animals they would be compensated
for their loss
there was a lot of resistance to this
idea especially among the older people
bachara presented the idea to a group of
young men they started with
yak calves the most valuable animals
charo helped them calculate what the
premiums would be
and he also chipped in some money for
the program and then it was up to the 25
young men to run it themselves
after a year they held a public event
where the participants presented their
claims
the men agreed that each person had to
swear on a photo of the dalai lama
that it was in fact a snow leopard that
killed his animals
and then they started giving money and
the rest of the village is watching
and the people who are getting
compensation are getting super happy
yeah
and now the entire village is like oh
what's happening
and these 25 people went to the village
elders
and then they were like oh we have done
this what he said
makes sense since then the insurance
program has continued to be successful
in qibla
you have to be immersing yourself in the
communities you have to be living with
them
you know sort of participating in their
way of life to the extent that you are
welcome
but really participating and really
trying to understand
what it is what is the community about
and how they live and the
hardships they face in living with these
predators etc
as people stopped killing snow leopards
they began to see the cats around kibber
charo finally saw one after living there
for 10 years
and then in 2015 the road that leads to
kibber
opened for the first time in the winter
and slowly word got out that kemper was
a good place to see snow leopards
we spent several days hiking into the
mountains to check the cameras
but the snow leopards always seemed to
elude procengine's traps
we were getting pretty frustrated and
then like a lightning strike
word came that kunkidar had made a
spectacular kill
prasajjit in a hurried to a spot on a
cliff overlooking the spithy river
where dozens of tourists had their
cameras pointed down into the gorge
we found a tour guide named janth sharma
who told us he'd seen a snow leopard
chasing the large ibex the two animals
fell
onto a ledge and then rolled and then
fell some more nearly a thousand feet to
the bottom of the gorge
and into the freezing river he was
rolling down with ibex oh my goodness so
the ibex we couldn't see the snow
leopard we saw the ibex rolling down
but the snow leopard is probably one
third the size of the ibex so
the ibex was struggling to get out of
the frigid water but kunkidar wasn't
giving up his meal
he pulled the ibex down and held its
head under the water until it died
but the snow leopard left the kill early
in the morning and no one had seen him
since
some of the guides were speculating he
may have been injured making the kill
we spend the rest of the day scanning
the gorge with high-powered binoculars
and telephoto lenses
looking for signs of kunkadar and then
finally just before dusk
the snow leopard emerges from the
shadows and returns to its kill
man that ibex is so huge it's like a big
stone in the middle of the river
and the snow leopard literally jumped on
it
it's standing on the ibex and eating
diabetes
so by standing on the ibex it's avoiding
the water
from the stream and then it's pulling
and it's ripping it apart and
i steady my binoculars and focus on the
cat i mean it looks
tiny standing on this massive ibex at
one point the snow leopard looks up
and i feel like he's staring at me i
mean what would make
an old male snow leopard
be willing to take on i mean you know
something almost three times
its size hunger
and the other thing is this ibex itself
wasn't
was really old so we knew like
it's been a chatter in last two weeks
in the entire village that this guy is
soon gonna get killed by snow leopard
because it would just not run away walk
on the road
let me ask you this question so why what
is it about a snow leopard
that brings us all the way up here to
this remote part of the himalayas
and puts us right out on the edge of a
600 meter
sheer cliff to get a glimpse of this
thing
eating an ibex in the middle of the
river what is
what is about that that drives human
beings to do that
imagine a big cat that lives high up in
the himalayas
in minus 40 degrees celsius climbs these
steep cliffs runs on them and then
catches a goat
and then feeds on it and animals which
has been
so elusive like like the word elusive
is probably made for the species
and that is the reason why what what
brought me up here that is the reason
why i brought you up here and all these
people as well
in 2020 that excitement for these
animals brought more than 200 tourists
to kibber
and they spent about a hundred thousand
dollars there which represents a huge
source of new revenue for the village
but tourism in kibber is increasing at a
rate that's been overwhelming for the
village
there aren't any formal hotels visitors
rent rooms from the locals
no one has running water so water has to
be carried to each home
and tourists bring in a lot of trash
that has to be burned or taken down
tourism as we know while on the one hand
it brings benefits to people at the
other hand
on the other hand there's so many
ecological negative ecological cultural
and other impacts that it can have
according to chara there are
conversations happening in the spiti
valley
about how to manage tourism sustainably
he's optimistic people can see the snow
leopards without exhausting natural
resources at the same time
but he emphasizes like with the
insurance program
it's up to the locals to figure out what
works best for them
[Music]
about a week after i left kibber i got a
sad call from prossenjeet
the old snow leopard kunkadar had died
i have a feeling that probably it got a
little bit injured when it tried to make
the skill of this ibex
and eventually when it tried to make
another attempt
it didn't go really well it made a dash
with this
this blue sheep and they both fell down
very deep into the gorge
and the snorla died on the spot the
forestry department recovered the body
and the village held a cremation
ceremony for it i mean
till that point i think my story was
about
smaller birds and then suddenly i
realized
that that story is about this individual
and a new generation of snow leopards is
already prowling the cliffs around the
spitty river
prasanji heard from friends in kibber
that one of his camera traps had gotten
some new footage
i've just heard that we have got this
video
of a female and two of her cubs coming
and literally
playing with the camera trap jumping
hanging on the stone playing amongst
themselves
and there is a point when all three of
them are looking at the camera trap
prostitute had to leave kibber not long
after i did because of the coronavirus
pandemic
and the village closed its doors to
visitors but he's looking forward to
going back
and when kibber reopens visitors will
return
and if they're patient and lucky they
just might get to see a snow leopard
and we should get there before it gets
dark because the
trek here is not very good to do at
night time
more after this
hey if you want to see the snow leopards
procenge captured with this camera traps
and i'm telling you you totally do you
can check them out on his instagram page
at proson.yadav and national geographic
subscribers can check out the piece i
wrote for the magazine
the himalayas ghost leopards so for any
super fans who've already read the piece
in national geographic
we have an update on the cubs situation
crossing g that spotted three cubs with
a female that were believed to be kung
kidar's offspring
months later after the magazine story
had published he finally got to see the
camera trap video of the cubs
and only two were visible no one is sure
if the other cubs survived
that's all in the show notes they're
right there in your podcast app
overheard at national geographic is
produced by brian gutierrez
jacob pinter and laura sim our senior
editor is eli chin
who also produced this episode thanks
eli
executive producer of audio is davar
ardellon
who edited this episode our fact
checkers are michelle harris and robin
palmer
our copy editor is amy kolczak
ted woods engineered this episode and
hansdale sue composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter guinn thanks for
listening
and see y'all next time
[Music]
you